y que nuestra laringe creciera desde 7 centímetros en los primates
a 11 y hasta 17 centímetros en los humanos.
A eso se le conoce como el descenso de la laringe.
Y en la laringe es donde se ubica la voz.
Cuando los bebés humanos nacen, la laringe aún no ha descendido.
Eso solo ocurre cerca de los tres meses.
Así que, metafóricamente, cada uno de nosotros
ha revivido la evolución de toda nuestra especie.
Y hablando de bebés,
cuando comenzamos a desarrollarnos en el vientre de nuestra madre,
la primera sensación que tuvimos del mundo exterior,
con tan solo tres semanas y apenas el tamaño de un camarón,
fue a través de la sensación táctil
que venía de las vibraciones de la voz de nuestra madre.
Como pueden ver, la voz humana es muy significativa e importante
como especie,
como sociedad
--así es como nos comunicamos y creamos lazos--
y al nivel personal e interpersonal.
Con nuestra voz compartimos mucho más que palabras e información,
básicamente compartimos quiénes somos.
Y nuestra voz es indistinguible de cómo la gente nos ve.
Es una máscara que nos ponemos en sociedad.
Pero la relación con nuestra propia voz no es tan obvia.
Rara vez la usamos con nosotros mismos; la usamos como un regalo para otros.
Es cómo nos tocamos unos a otros.
Es un ejercicio dialéctico.
Pero ¿qué pensamos de nuestra propia voz?
Por favor, levanten la mano
si no les gusta el sonido de su voz al escucharla en una grabación.
(Risas)
Claro, gracias, por supuesto,
mucha gente declara que no le gusta el sonido de su voz en una grabación.
¿Qué significa eso?
Intentemos comprenderlo en los próximos 10 minutos.
Soy investigadora en el laboratorio de medios del MIT,
parte del grupo Ópera del Futuro,
y mi investigación se enfoca en la relación
que tiene la gente con su propia voz y con la de otros.
Estudio lo que podemos aprender al escuchar voces,
desde varios campos,
desde la neurología, hasta la biología, las ciencias cognitivas, la lingüística.
En nuestro grupo creamos herramientas y experiencias
para ayudar a la gente a obtener un mejor conocimiento de su voz
para reducir los prejuicios,
convertirse en mejores oyentes,
crear relaciones más sanas
o solo para comprenderse mejor a sí mismos.
Y esto tiene que ir acompañado con un enfoque holístico de la voz.
Porque, piensen en todas las aplicaciones e implicaciones
que puede tener la voz, a medida que descubrimos más de ella.
La voz es un fenómeno muy complejo.
Requiere de una sincronización de más de 100 músculos.
Y al escuchar la voz,
podemos comprender posibles fallas de lo que pasa en el interior.
Por ejemplo:
escuchar ciertos tipos muy específicos de perturbaciones
y una falta de linealidad en la voz
puede ayudar a predecir etapas muy tempranas del párkinson
con solo una llamada telefónica.
Escuchar la respiración al hablar, puede ayudar a detectar una enfermedad cardiaca.
Y también sabemos que los cambios de ritmo en palabras individuales
son un buen indicador de depresión.
La voz también está muy ligada a los niveles hormonales.
Terceros, al escuchar voces femeninas
fueron capaces de ubicar muy acertadamente a las hablantes
según su ciclo menstrual.
Solo con la información acústica.
Y ahora con la tecnología escuchándonos todo el tiempo,
Alexa de Amazon Echo
puede ser capaz de predecir si están embarazadas
incluso antes de que lo sepan.
Así que piénsenlo...
(Risas)
Piensen en la implicación ética de esto.
La voz también está ligada a cómo nos relacionamos.
Tenemos distintas voces para cada persona con la que hablamos.
Si tomo un pequeño fragmento de su voz y la analizo,
puedo saber si están hablando con su madre, su hermano,
su amigo o su jefe.
También podemos usar el tono vocal como un predictor,
es decir, cómo deciden colocar la voz al hablar con alguien.
Su tono vocal cuando hablan con su cónyuge,
puede ayudar a predecir, no solo si se van a divorciar, sino cuándo.
Así que hay mucho que aprender de escuchar voces.
Y creo que esto debe empezar sabiendo
que tenemos más de una voz.
Así que, les hablaré de las tres voces que la mayoría poseemos,
en un modelo que llamo "la máscara".
Bien, cuando ven la máscara,
lo que ven es una proyección de un personaje.
Llamémosla "la voz externa".
Esta es la forma de pensar más típica sobre nuestra voz,
es una forma de proyectarse en el mundo.
El mecanismo para esta proyección es bien conocido.
Los pulmones contraen el diafragma
y eso crea una vibración autónoma de las cuerdas vocales
que crea un sonido.
Y luego, según como uno abre y cierra las cavidades en la boca,
el tracto vocal transformará el sonido.
Todos tenemos el mismo mecanismo.
Pero las voces son únicas.
Esto se debe a diferencias muy sutiles en tamaño, fisiología, niveles hormonales,
que marcarán diferencias muy sutiles en la voz externa.
Y el cerebro es muy bueno
para captar esas diferencias sutiles de las voces externas de otras personas.
En nuestro laboratorio, trabajamos con máquinas de enseñanza
para comprender esas diferencias sutiles.
Utilizamos aprendizaje profundo para crear sistemas de identificación en tiempo real
para ayudar a concienciar en el uso del espacio vocal compartido
--quién habla y quién nunca lo hace durante las reuniones--
para incrementar la inteligencia grupal.
Y una de las dificultades es que la voz no es estática.
Ya dijimos que esta cambia con cada persona con la que hablamos
pero, generalmente, también cambia a lo largo de la vida.
Al inicio y al final del viaje,
las voces masculinas y femeninas son muy parecidas.
Es muy difícil distinguir
la voz de una niñita de la voz de un niñito.
Pero en el ínterin, la voz se vuelve un diferenciador de la identidad fluida.
Generalmente, las voces masculinas tienen un cambio notable en la pubertad.
Y las voces femeninas
cambian con cada embarazo y tienen un gran cambio en la menopausia.
Todo eso es la voz que otras personas escuchan cuando Uds. hablan.
Así que, ¿por qué no estamos tan familiarizados con ella?
¿Por qué no es la voz que nosotros escuchamos?
Pensemos en ello.
Cuando usamos una máscara, realmente no la vemos.
Y cuando intentamos observarla, lo que vemos es el interior de ella.
Esa es la voz interna.
Entonces, para comprender por qué es diferente,
intentemos entender el mecanismo de percepción de esta voz interna,
ya que el cuerpo tiene muchas maneras de filtrarla en forma diferente
a la voz externa.
Así que, para percibir esta voz, primero tiene que viajar hasta los oídos.
Y la voz externa viaja por el aire
mientras que la voz interna viaja por los huesos.
A esto se le llama conducción ósea.
Debido a ello, la voz interna sonará con un registro más bajo
y también más armoniosa musicalmente que la voz externa.
Una vez que viaja ahí, tiene acceso al oído interno.
Y tenemos otro mecanismo que interviene aquí.
Es un filtro mecánico,
una pequeña partición que aparece y protege al oído interno
cada vez que producimos un sonido.
Así que también reduce lo que oímos.
Y luego tenemos un tercer filtro, un filtro biológico.
La cóclea --una parte del oído interno que procesa el sonido--
está hecha de células vivas.
Esas células vivas se activarán de manera distinta
según qué tan frecuentemente escuchen un sonido.
Es un efecto de habituación.
Debido a esto,
como nuestra voz es el sonido que escuchamos con mayor frecuencia,
es el que menos percibimos.
Por último, tenemos un cuarto filtro.
Es un filtro neurológico.
Los neurólogos han descubierto recientemente
que cuando abrimos la boca para crear un sonido,
nuestra propia corteza auditiva se apaga.
Así que oímos nuestra voz
pero el cerebro nunca escucha el sonido de nuestra voz.
Evolutivamente, eso puede tener sentido,
porque sabemos cognitivamente cómo vamos a sonar,
por ello, tal vez no necesitamos gastar energía en analizar la señal.
A esto se le llama descarga corolario
y ocurre con cada movimiento de nuestro cuerpo.
La definición exacta de una descarga corolario es
una copia de un comando motor que envía el cerebro.
Esta copia no crea un movimiento por sí misma,
sino que es enviada a otras regiones del cerebro
para informarles sobre el próximo movimiento.
Y para la voz, esta descarga corolario también tiene otro nombre.
Es la voz interior.
Recapitulemos.
Tenemos la máscara --la voz externa--,
el interior de la máscara --la voz interna--
y después tenemos la voz interior.
Me gusta ver esto como el titiritero
que sostiene las cuerdas de todo el sistema.
La voz interior es
la que escuchan cuando leen un texto en silencio,
cuando ensayan para una conversación importante.
A veces es difícil apagarla,
es muy difícil ver un texto escrito en nuestra lengua nativa
sin leerlo con esta voz interior.
También es la voz que se rehúsa a dejar de cantar
la estúpida canción que tienen en la cabeza.
(Risas)
Y para algunas personas resulta imposible controlarla.
Y ese es el caso de los pacientes con esquizofrenia,
que tienen alucinaciones auditivas.
No pueden distinguir entre las voces que vienen del interior
de las que vienen del exterior.
En nuestro laboratorio, también trabajamos con aparatos pequeños
para ayudar a que esas personas hagan esas distinciones
y sepan si una voz es interna o externa.
También pueden pensar en la voz interior como aquella que habla en nuestros sueños.
La voz interior puede tomar distintas formas.
En nuestros sueños podemos desatar el potencial de esta voz.
Ese es otro de los trabajos que hacemos en el laboratorio:
tratamos de acceder a esta voz interior de los sueños.
Así que, aunque no siempre puedan controlarla,
siempre pueden interactuar con ella
a través del diálogo, de los diálogos internos.
Y siempre pueden ver esta voz interior
como el enlace perdido entre los pensamientos y las acciones.
Así que, espero haberlos dejado con una mejor apreciación,
una nueva apreciación de todas sus voces
y el rol que juegan dentro y fuera de Uds.,
porque su voz es un determinante crítico de lo que los hace humanos
y de cómo interactúan con el mundo.
Gracias
(Aplausos)